à new york maintenant on retrouve
l'architecte daniel laporte qui habite
new york depuis 24 ans qui habitait donc
à quelques rues détour le jour de
l'attentât monsieur laporte bonsoir
bonsoir monsieur fillion vous étiez là
vous étiez là vous avez vécu pleinement
les événements du 11 septembre 2001
décrivez-nous cette journée du 11
septembre
1 ouais c'est ça fait là c'est spécial
d'avoir parlé dont j'habite sur une rue
qui était en pleine ligne avec la tour
nord une très belle rues pour prendre
des photos est en fait le premier avion
fait un bruit énorme en passant au
dessus de nos têtes et je suis sorti sur
mon bâton 1 j'ai vu à peu près cinq
secondes après l'impact
le trou dans la tour nord
et donc vous habitiez tout près vous
viviez depuis plusieurs années à ce
moment là nous y sommes vous avez une
vie vous aviez vous avez toujours une
vie new yorkaise vous êtes architecte
oui tout à fait et à cette époque
j'avais une
agence à ces jeunes ça faisait quatre
ans
donc oui mais je pratiquais l'architecte
est ce que vous avez pensé
changer d'emploi changer de ville quitté
partir à ce moment là
c'est assez spécial comme une sensation
sur le coup non
vraiment au même au contraire c'est dans
les moments difficiles qu'on voit
vraiment le caractère déjà et new york
c'est vraiment
instantanément
serré les mains et travailler ensemble
pour repartir pour sauver les gens c'est
vraiment ça a commencé j'ai ptet est à
peu près sept minutes à pied de des taux
donc
c'était pour aller aider les gens donc
tout le monde s'est mis ensemble
c'est frappé les tours comme les
terroristes l'ont fait c'est frappé le
capitalisme en plein coeur ce site était
plus que symbolique là c'était vraiment
de frapper le plus durement possible est
ce qui a été réussi mais en même temps
vous qui vivez à new york depuis 20 ans
est ce que l'économie ce que le
capitalisme j'oserais dire à changer
selon vous
oui je crois que
c'est indépendamment peut-être cette
attaque le capital de
la séparation entre le
capital et les gens c'est beaucoup plus
distancé depuis ces vingt dernières
années
particulièrement moi je travaille dans
la catégorie haut de gamme et donc les
maisons résidentielles privée donc je
vois définitivement
un changement par rapport à ça
donc les écarts de richesse sont encore
plus grands qu'ils étaient les
inégalités sociales économiques qu'est
ce qui a quand même changé selon vous
fondamentalement c'était un moment où
tout était mis sur pause
donc on sait
personnes s'attendent à ce que ça se
passe c'est un moment où tout le monde
ici ont réévalué la situation
but leur but dans la vie leur but
professionnel donc ça permet moi ça m'a
permis personnellement de
réajuster
vient juste et mon tir par mon agent
c'est parce que tout d'un coup
heureusement la vie est courte et ici ça
peut passer tellement vite à new york on
s'en rend pas compte donc par rapport au
jeu personnellement par rapport à ma
propre pratique j'ai su d'un coup
travailler plus fort médoc aussi
prioriser un peu plus la vie personnelle
est ce qu'elle est ce que vous trouvez
que tout a repris rapidement après assez
rapidement je dirais dans l'année ah
c'est encore là une des raisons comme je
disais au début que new york on se rend
compte que c'est une ville assez
particulière que
n'importe quoi qu'il arrive il ya
soixante ça se retourne assez rapidement
si ça bouge et est possible d avantage
face à vous quelles sont les
conséquences ou les effets que vous
remarquez encore aujourd'hui et qui
vient
de ces attentats du 11 septembre
la résilience la résilience des gens new
york on était frappé nous apprennent
très récemment par la pandémie vous
savez
c'est le fait de le fait des tours et
tous les petits événements eu lieu un
groupe black out et d'électricité
samedi et après le 11 septembre c'est
comment on voit que les gens ce vont se
mettre ensemble mais bon c'est le
royaume de l'individualisme ici mais
quand il ya un événement tout le monde
c'est l'ensemble et je pense que la
première fois que ça c'est vraiment
manifesté ce fut lors durant sept ans
vous êtes à new york encore vingt ans
plus tard vous rester à new york
j'habite j'habite à peu près cinq
minutes d'où j'habite est qu encore du
taux ont été
attaqués en quatre langues le mail et
vous allez rester à new york oui tout à
fait
mon enfant je ne fais qu est né ici
qu'ils vendent au fait des risques au
fait si votre ville ouais c'est devenu
ma deuxième fils en fait j'ai toujours
ma première monsieur laporte merci
d'avoir été avec nous appeler pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne ici et redit
oh